I mean look at that
no it's so why is it it's the bones in
there to something
[Music]
hello uh I'm Stephen Graham and today
we're doing snack Wars for land Bible
and it's north versus South three two
one boom
[Music]
is it gonna be fish and chips that we
reckon or
oh okay but now hang on what kind of
sausage is that then
all right so that's yourself
I'm taking I guess chips and curry sauce
chips and water
so this is actually from Liverpool is
this salt and pepper chips
chips
okay I didn't know that I'm Your Man
[Music]
it's all right old is a little cake
there now yeah yeah that's all right
yeah right that's not bad
oh that looks a bit Snyder doesn't it
I mean
I think I think what you may however
um all right yeah let's just okay
I mean this is like something I give our
dogs by the locals that's all right
remember me
okay I'm starting to suck that salt and
pepper chips wins that one okay
it's the one thing I thought so [__]
oh where is this that I mean can we show
people what I've got to have a go out
here
yeah can you see that
used bike I mean it isn't even a date on
it you know what I mean so it's like
this is nuclear this will stay when
we're all gone this will still be on a
shield
[Laughter]
oh man
have you had this before no okay
and there's a reason off of I mean I
can't even get
um
that celebrity get me out of here
wouldn't it I don't know if I can do
this
this girl a little bit
it's so why is it is the bones in there
or something
all right
[Music]
now
yeah
it's like giving an octopus a [__]
now
and this is what's that I mean who's
Nana invented this it's from the
Northeast I can imagine please
oh this is
what actually do we know what's going on
it's just like like Millions Haze and
like with a bit of spices going yeah
all right
laughs
[Music]
now
[Applause]
can we just say that's that's a null and
void that's that's no one gets a point
for that because that's not right given
any points for any of that there has to
be a winner there has to be a winner
you're mean
all right well if that asset I'm sucking
a slip around them noshing off the
octopus yeah so that's it give that away
that's horrific
I've many people being sick when they've
done this before
I think Sam fender with the Jelly deals
was the closest I can't I can't believe
oh God
[Applause]
but I think it's the jelly deals has
been the only time when people have
really stopped doing that it's not nice
or keep doing it for everyone and see
who you actually make goldfish oh
uh uh excuse me I'm so sorry
oh
excuse me Sonny honey if I'm embarrassed
you
excuse me I'm so sorry that was that
jelly deal
come to the Lake District okay
there's a lot of time going into this a
lot of care and a lot of dedication oh
wow now that's look at that that's next
level in it oh wow
[Music]
oh this is gonna be this is going to be
special
in fact
I might save that for a second that's it
right we all know what this is
but I'll just say it's fun but I'm
Australian
it's Up For Debate it's gone
it's gone
so what about scone who says scone
you're a scone
I'm not kicking off I'm just saying
you're a scum Okay so we've had more
scones than scones
okay that's how it tastes
[Music]
four minutes will be you know again
it's really tasty it's quite fresh
more local
um a cardo delivery this morning
that's actually a little bit more about
yourself
um
right this I mean this I mean look at
that layout look at that I mean
you know we're getting involved with a
biscuit you know what I mean
oh
if you tried this yeah it's really good
oh is everyone how to go with this
no
um
[Music]
[Laughter]
catch
snapping It Off
right can we can we I wish I could take
the camera now and show everyone
oh let's munching this that's going on
back there
I think he's got a bit of Ginger biscuit
just because of the smiles it's brought
to all your faces
um then I was an experience I wasn't
expecting thank you
scumpy pies
oh Jesus
wanted to come down to there's your
cheese and onion proper cheese and onion
I opened the packet like salt not
because I'm gonna Munch them all but
these are all going to help me on this
one
so so is it all going to come in camera
running and you're all going to take one
of each and then go back and I'll ask
you all the questions yourselves again
okay so I'm going to take my weapons of
choice please come in and help me out
with everyone because it's very close
keep the camera on it's very close we
have to you know we've got to go down
this
this may I mean I'll ultimately have the
final decision but I think we should all
get involved here yeah
thank you okay come on
come on come on out thank you
yes come on set thank you all right now
look we're going on this one first yeah
let's go scampi first one two three
thank you
give it a second
really good yeah yeah okay
cheese and onion let's go
[Music]
okay wait there
okay
cheese onion raise your hand
[Music]
s
scampi let yourself be known
okay so ladies and gentlemen our viewers
at home or in the workplace or wherever
you may be watching this scintillating
final round of uh
food challenge the winner is by a
majority decision may I add
so here's to the trusty rather
delightful
stamping
thank you very much in that game it's
not close the north one yes
foreign
[Applause]
why jelly who came up with that as
disgusting